if there's one issue that can bring
Democrats and Republicans together it's
UFOs why is the military and the
government not just being honest with us
why are they over classifying it why
aren't they being transparent they keep
telling us they don't exist but they
block every opportunity for us to get a
hold of the information to prove that
they do exist and we're going to get to
the bottom of it Dad government whatever
the truth may be
we're done with the cover-ups
dad gummit the house oversight committee
announcing a hearing with actual
eyewitnesses for what the government
calls uap's unidentified Ariel phenomena
and the bite Administration this week
admitting that these things are having
an actual impact on our military some of
these phenomena we know have already had
an impact on our training ranges for you
know when Pilots are out trying to do
training in the air and they see these
things they're not sure what they are
and it can have an impact on their
ability to perfect their skills there's
something our Pilots are seeing
that's reassuring joining me now is
Jeremy Corbell investigative journalist
and co-host of weaponize it's a podcast
that explores The Unexplained Jeremy
what do we know about these some things
that Pilots are seeing that I guess
they're interfering even with training
missions
well our government knows a lot about
them but the public does not and the
issue is really it doesn't matter where
these machines are from we know they
outpace out maneuver and over perform
any of our Weaponry we know they're not
China we know they're not Russia we know
they're not ours so what we're looking
to do is avoid strategic surprise it
doesn't matter where UFOs are from what
matters is we don't have a 360 view of
what's going on in our airspace for the
safety of our Pilots but also for the
safety of America so that's what this
hearing is about this unprecedented
hearing unlike anything that has ever
come before well a lot of the Skeptics
are saying well this is just this is new
technology that's coming from China or
Russia and Congressman uh burchett had a
really good retort to that claim
if Russia owned it we they wouldn't be
battling in Ukraine he'd be over China
they would control us even they pretty
much do now even more so since either
something from that's extraterrestrial
or something that we that we have in our
Skunk Works and listen to the pilots it
defies all of our laws of physics the
human body would not be able to
withstand the pressure from this thing
it's it's beyond belief
Jeremy I just want to hear more and more
and more on this I mean yes all in
America the whole world is fascinated by
this because guess what UFOs have been a
part of The Human Experience since
before there was even a pentagon or a
Department of Defense so this idea that
it's just some technology built by
another unknown Nation it doesn't hold
water so the question is who's operating
this craft what's the intent how do they
have these performance capabilities it's
really important to understand this is
not a new topic you go all the way back
to presidencies way back in the day and
people ran on tickets to tell the truth
about UFOs so it's about time and we're
getting closer and closer with every day
these hearings are historic firsthand
direct eyewitnesses people that have
actually engaged UFOs in combat
situations even training so that's what
we're going to see come next week Jeremy
can you explain for us to the extent
that you know this
how are these operating from what they
can understand that defy the laws of
physics to put the pressure on a regular
human pilot that would be unsustainable
by the human body explain that
right so that that's a huge story but
essentially it has to do with the with
the propulsion systems themselves what I
can tell you is what we're observing not
how it works that's what we need to find
out what we're observing are objects
that can go what they call Trans medium
from space to air to sea without any
inertial effect so they're able to go at
right angle turns at thousands of miles
an hour this is something that we have
radar footage satellite footage of the
public deserves to know this exists and
then the question becomes who's are they
well doesn't it seem that when we've
been hearing about the pieces of
things that seem like aircraft that have
been recovered and are being examined
somewhere but we don't know we think
it's like the night of the museum like
there's all these things that are
talking to each other in the middle of
the night it was a movie about that
um but it where are these items I'm not
going to say space spacecraft but where
are these vehicles
Senator Harry Reid pointed the finger at
Lockheed but there are a number of these
uh holding facilities and I hope we hear
more about that when it comes to the
hearings because those places have been
told to arrow and other organizations
all right Jeremy great to see you
tonight we cannot wait for this hearing
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else